Kerson ville martyr depuis le retrait
russe et la reprise de cette ville du
sud de l'Ukraine il y a dix jours par
les forces ukrainiennes Kiev ne cesse de
dénoncer les exactions ainsi le parquet
général ukrainien dit notamment avoir
découvert de nouvelles preuves de crimes
de guerre 4 cycles de torture présumées
auraient été découvert notamment par les
autorités ukrainiennes ces dernières
heures sur place les précisions notre
envoyé spécial taligny
4 sites de torture ont été découverts
dans des immeubles de civils que les
troupes russes transformées en centre de
détention provisoire hier on a traversé
des villages récemment libérés et les
habitants nous racontaient comment ils
regardaient impuissants leurs voisins se
faire embarquer ou plutôt kidnapper
comme il le disent de façon complètement
arbitraire on nous indiquait que il
suffisait parfois d'avoir ne serait-ce
qu'une photo arborant le drapeau
ukrainien ou bien des poèmes
patriotiques dans leur téléphone pour se
faire arrêter et les les rescapés qui
qui commencent à témoigner sur ce qu'ils
ont subi ils parlent d'électrochocs
qu'ils ont reçu à la tête sur leurs
doigts sur leur partie génitales ou bien
il raconte qu'il se faisait frapper par
des battes de baseball ou bien des
barres en métal mais au-delà des cas de
torture la population ukrainienne elle a
été plongée dans un climat de terreur
quotidien par les forces russes hier
justement on discutait avec un fermier
d'un village qui nous racontait que lui
et ses voisins avaient été
ciblés par des alors qu'ils essayaient
simplement de rejoindre le village
voisin pour rendre visite à leurs
proches ou bien on nous a parlé aussi de
cas de grande humiliation ce fermier qui
s'appelle volozimir et nous a raconté
qu'une fois il s'est retrouvé face à un
soldat russe qui a pointé une arme
automatique sur lui et qu'il a menacé en
lui disant vas-y montre moi combien tu
peux courir vite pour atteindre la
voiture d'à côté donc vraiment un
quotidien terrifiant pour ses habitants
et et on le sent dans dans leur voix
dans leur regard qu'ils sont certes
soulagés d'être libérés d'être Prusse
mais que en même temps il reste
profondément traumatisé par ces 8 mois
d'occupation